across ukraine peaceful lives have been
shattered by incessant bombing while
homes and infrastructure have been
destroyed one of the most devastated
cities is the besieged port of mariopol
where ukraine says 100 000 civilians are
trapped without food water or medication
in a hospital in kiev aliya is feeding
her daughter victoria who is just one
month old the baby survived russian
shelling because her mother used her
body as a shield her father recounts how
their apartment block was targeted
i woke up because olya was screaming and
it was accompanied by the sound of glass
crashing an alarm fire a catastrophe
i just heard all your shouting turned
over and threw a blanket over them
attacks on residential areas schools and
hospitals have become a daily occurrence
in the war
with russian troops mostly stalled
outside ukraine's main cities they are
resorting to bombing from afar
speaking in english and appealing to the
world ukrainian president zelensky
called for a universal show of support
come to your squares your streets make
yourselves visible and heard say that
people matter freedom matters peace
matters ukraine matters russia is trying
to defeat the freedom of all people in
europe of all the people in the world it
tries to show that only crude and cruel
force matters
despite the destruction russia has
wrought ukraine says it will not give up
fighting
but the price of its defiance is a
country laid to waste
and to bring us up to date i'm joined by
our correspondent funny facial she's in
levive in western ukraine fanny thanks
for joining us this morning give us the
latest what are you hearing where you
are in
ukraine as you have just heard in that
report the devastation the shelling the
explosions continue to especially hit
hard mario paul we have heard so much
about that town which is really bearing
the brunt in all of this where you
really get the most harrying pictures
from and
not only mario paul obviously other
parts in the donbass region as well uh
also towards the north places like
kharkiv had son tsumi all names that
basically the world got to know during
the past four weeks when this war began
but also explosions reported from kiev
so the situation here in ukraine remains
very very dire for so many people
millions are displaced at least one
quarter of the ukrainian population has
been displaced many of them have left
towards the polish or romanian border
across the border but at least six
million are displaced internally because
of this war that began exactly one month
ago today on february 24th
now president zielenski has asked people
around the world to protest against the
war what do you make of this call do you
think people will answer this call to
action
we have seen demonstrations worldwide in
many parts of europe and elsewhere even
before prior to this announcement what i
make what i find quite interesting in
that call to take to the streets that he
actually did it in three languages in
russian in english and in ukrainian and
especially in russian he made clear that
the russians should also realize that
this is not their war and they shouldn't
basically buy into this russian
propaganda he says but he also called on
the politicians there are several
summits to take place today g7 nato
summit eu summit president biden is also
here in is also in europe and so he
called basically on politicians to not
risk a division amongst them but to
actually also have a unified response to
stop this war so very emotional address
once again from president zelinski there
but what's quite interesting here in
ukraine the people who actually decide
to return to this country now against
all odds and despite the war that's
going on we met one woman here in lev
who wants to show resistance by
returning here and help her local staff
to secure their jobs let's have a listen
they escaped horror their last stretch
boarding one of these trains to poland
liuba and her two grandchildren took
four days to get here from harkief a
city heavily bumped
horrible things are happening
there are bombings dead bodies are lying
around in the village
two villagers were completely destroyed
her grandchild 16 year old carol doesn't
know if he will ever return to ukraine
i will stay with my parents in poland i
will study and live there somehow
the images of people fleeing ukraine
most of them women and children
ingrained
however a small but growing number is
headed back to ukraine most of the men
ready to fight but it's estimated one in
five is a woman
a woman like lilia a designer she fled
from keith on the day the war began to
france now she is back
it's impossible to leave my team behind
i need to give people jobs faith in the
future
that's why i'm here
my return is about supporting ukraine
and those who don't know whether to
return or what to do how to live
shaken by the brutality of this war she
says she wants to secure jobs for her
team who all had to flee from keefe
she's able to give work again in this
wedding dress factory she found a
temporary workspace
my message to all women who are abroad
and who may think about returning and
what to do here
i want to tell them
we have the strongest men in the world
despite the optimism the war is present
here too our interview interrupted by
air raid sirens
yeah now oh the airaid siren again
[Music]
girls if you want to go down go
oh it's terrible
yeah yeah yeah yeah um
the factory can be a target too lilia
explains as we head to the bunker
but just how responsible is it to ask
others to return to ukraine now lilia
makes clear
everyone is responsible for their own
actions
and everyone decides for themselves what
they do
but they say the choices they make
what ukraine means to them
and the consequence of their choice of
leaving or returning places here at this
train station in livith
fanny the invasion started a month ago
you were in kiev at the time take us
back to that day what was it like
i remember basically waking up to what i
first thought was someone slamming the
hotel room door real real hard to then
realize that this was an explosion
followed by several other explosions
that early morning shortly after 4 am
it was a situation where people were
under shock when journalists that were
in the same hotel where we were staying
we're under shock people were basically
going down on the road to report while
others were remaining in the hotel
trying to report from their
balconies not knowing just is it really
the beginning of the war is it just a
few explosions and that's it so there
was confusion but especially shock on
the ground i've seen people who were
trying to flee as soon as they could
already by the way the way before the
door you could have this you could feel
this tense
atmosphere in the air and nobody even
when the war broke out when this
full-scale invasion began actually
thought that it's going to happen and we
spent there the week uh leading up to
this full-scale invasion and there was
so much speculation so much discussion
going on if there's going to be an
invasion and whether that's just going
to be just in quotes in the donbass
region or elsewhere so a day in history
four weeks ago where we still do not
know what the consequences the full
scale consequences are going to be as
this war wages on the russian war
against ukraine fannie farchar and levi
thanks so much for your reporting
and here's a look at some of the other
developments in the war
a reporter working for an independent
russian website has been killed in kiev
news outlet the insider said oksana
balina died when russian forces shelled
a suburb where she had been filming
damage from an attack at least five
journalists have now died since russian
troops invaded ukraine four weeks ago
a top kremlin aide has become the first
member of putin's inner circle to quit
his post over the russian invasion
anatoly chubais was putin's envoy to
international organizations but he's
better known as the architect of
russia's post-soviet economic reforms
poland has expelled 45 russian diplomats
accusing them of being kremlin spies the
gov government spokesperson said it was
part of warsaw's dismantling of the
russian special services network in
poland they've given most of the group
five days to leave the country
moscow has called the accusations absurd
now it's a big day for diplomacy in
brussels today with the leaders of nato
g7 and european union countries all
coming together for talks on how to deal
with the war in ukraine nato secretary
general jens stottenberg was among the
first to arrive for an emergency summit
of alliance leaders u.s president joe
biden is also in the belgian capital and
will be taking part in all of today's
consultations
now speaking ahead of the start of the
talks nato chief stoltenberg said
russian president vladimir putin made a
big mistake by invading ukraine and that
the alliance needed to prevent the
conflict from spreading
we
meet here at the nato headquarters
facing the most
serious
security crisis in the generation
we need to do more and therefore we need
to invest more and there is a new sense
of urgency but we have also made it
clear that uh
we will not send in uh
nato troops on the ground or
nato planes in the air
we do that because we have a
responsibility to
ensure that this conflict do not
escalate beyond ukraine that will cause
even more suffering even more death even
more destruction
and for more of that we can cross
straight to our brussels correspondent
bentley
but we just heard nato secretary general
stoltenberg there saying we need to do
more but also that nato won't put boots
on the ground or planes in the air how
can nato do more and are there any signs
that what they're doing is deterring
putin
some member states will deliver more
ammunition more anti-tank missiles and
more anti-aircraft missiles to ukraine
to the ukrainian army so that they can
fight but otherwise the military toolbox
of nato is quite empty and nato so far
was not able to deter the russian war
machine or even to influence the cause
of the war
nato is rather concentrating on its own
defense and calls
from
president zielenski of ukraine who will
be a guest via video link of this nato
summit
will go unanswered there will be no
no-fly zone
there will be no fighter jets for
ukraine so and and now
nato is in for in reinforcing its own
capacities there will be four more
battle groups uh stationed in the east
and also more troops from the united
states coming over but this is to
prevent that the war spills over and
that nato gets
drawn into this conflict so
not much
to deter russia actually
let's talk about unity the first days of
the war were marked by strong unity by
eu and nato members one month into this
conflict does that unity still hold
well it does the message of this three
summits today here in brussels is unity
and resolve there are internal
discussions about what can be done more
and more sanctions uh more help for
ukraine especially poland comes forward
with some
proposals like a piece keeping forced by
nato but this has no chance to be
realized because
other member states say that it will not
happen so the the front if you can say
that is quite united um and this is also
the purpose of this uh whole endeavor
today to show russia that the west is
still united on this and once an end of
the war and wants an end of the war
crimes
benrigert in brussels thanks so much
now vladimir putin believed his invasion
would result in a quick victory instead
his army has become embroiled in a
bitter war one that has seen the
russians target civilians a warning this
next report contains images that some of
our viewers may find distressing
an apartment block under fire
this is mario poll the ukrainian city
russia has been targeting since the
start of its invasion
[Music]
targets include its citizens
who've paid a heavy price
this distraught mother holds her
sleeping child
her other child was killed in russian
shelling
for those still here there's little left
we have nothing to eat it's awful it's
just awful no light no heat nothing
russian forces have attacked schools
yeah
he freed us from education
and community buildings
when this theater was bombed it was
acting as a shelter for hundreds of
people it's still unclear how many died
hospitals too have been targeted
[Music]
this pregnant woman who was filmed being
rescued from mario paul's maternity
hospital later died
half an hour after her baby was
delivered stillborn
since the war began a month ago there
have been more than 60 attacks on
ukrainian medical facilities including
hospitals according to the world health
organization
over the last few weeks russian air
power and artillery have struck at
residential areas in other cities like
kharkiv
how could this monster oh my god
monster come up with something like this
to destroy everything people are
starving there is no water no wood for
heating and he decided to destroy a city
in the 21st century a beautiful city
one month on it seems no one not even
children are safe in putin's war
i'm joined now by dw reporter roman
goncarenko from dw's russia ukraine and
eastern europe department roman it's
very difficult not to be terribly moved
by images that we've just seen in that
report it's clear that putin's war is
devastating ukraine
has this war though now also become a
disaster for russia
well yes of course but in a different
way so um russian cities are not bombed
russian children are not dying they are
not hiding in shelters
millions of russians are not fleeing the
country some are but it's a minority but
on the other hand of course it's a
disaster for russia because the russian
economy has been hit the hardest in the
fall of the soviet union and it's just
developing western imposing new and new
sanctions on russia
and this whole period 30 years after
1991
it's over it's done russia is a pariah
state now and it's a disaster
you mess you mentioned the western
sanctions that are crippling the russian
economy yesterday putin announced a plan
to try to force the west to boost his
economy let's take a quick listen
a number of western countries have taken
illegitimate decisions on the so-called
freezing of russian assets
[Music]
this collective west has actually drawn
a line under the reliability of its
currencies
you've already spoken about this it
crossed out the trust in these
currencies
could this attempt to force western
countries to pay for gas in ruble's work
given
many european countries are very
dependent on russian gas
well um we don't know because it's a
completely new situation we've never had
it and it could work for some time at
least because um western countries
especially here in europe are very
dependent on russian gas but on the
other hand they are making plans to get
rid of that dependence by the end of
this year
my guess is that this will happen sooner
and um
russian plan to to support its own
currency to support its central bank
sanctioned by the west will probably
work for a couple of weeks or a couple
of months at most but then i think the
sanctions will force also the western
side to get rid of russian gas and to
stop to end that dependency
um we've been hearing this morning
ukrainian forces have made advances
against the russian navy near the port
city of badansk what more can you tell
us about that
well it's a new development and we have
some reports from ukraine that in the
occupied city of badanks on the sea of
azov uh some ukrainian parties science
uh managed to um to attack a russian
ship a big warship
it's probably the biggest
success for the ukrainian army um so far
on the on on sea against russian
warships we know uh reports that the
ship sank and we know that the ship was
the first to come to the occupied city
of berdank's a few days ago and it
brought a load of apc's armored
personnel carriers it's it's a ship that
could carry up to 40 apcs up to 20 tanks
so it's a huge loss for the russian army
roman goncharenko from dw's russia
ukraine and eastern europe department
thanks so much
you